dernier jour avant les premières
épreuves du bac 2006 pour les candidats
habitués à utiliser des calculatrices
attention la fraude
certaines mémoires sont en effet
capables de stocker des courses entier
françois jullien pieds-noirs guillaume
foutra mari qu elle se multiplie à
l'infini
aujourd'hui on ne compte plus les
nouveaux modèles de calculatrice et
l'équation est simple une grande mémoire
plus une rapidité d'exécution égale des
petits ordinateurs prêt pour le bac que
saisirons toute chose on peut même aller
sur internet sur certains modèles on
peut même trouver des jeux sur internet
donc c'est un oui on peut même décoré
petit conseil sur la calculatrice je
vous rappelle que vous avez droit
une calculatrice une seule calculatrice
mais dans laquelle aujourd'hui on stocke
bien plus que les simples formules
d'autoriser la calculatrice de richard
est pleine donc j'ai tous mes programmes
de chimie sur celle là et puis il ya les
la bassée l'oeuf a vu pas pris
donc si je vois qu'il arrive vous autant
quitter tout de suite enfin ben on vous
cherche énorme qui surveille les examens
mais peuvent pas le moyen de virer
regarder le contenu des calculatrices et
en aucun cas ils peuvent sont
tranquilles eux mettent ce qu'ils
veulent en option al'approche du bac les
sites internet dédiés à la triche sur
calculatrice fleurissent pour sa
prochaine épreuve de commerce
victor a déjà tapé quelques antisèches
électronique marge sur coûts variables
égale chiffre d'affaires - les charges
variables
la majorité des élèves triche comme ça
parce que c'est un moyen très très
facile et où es tu ou s'il le faut selon
le ministère de l'éducation nationale en
2005 seul un élève a été prise en
flagrant délit de fraude à la
calculatrice le règlement d'examen ne
prévoit pas qu'on vide les mémoires
thèses des calculatrices ne prévoit pas
en contrôle de ses mémoires
mais d'une manière générale les sujets
qui sont proposées aux élèves ne
permettent pas à ses élèves de fraude et
grâce à ses calculatrices
le calcul est donc vite fait
mieux vaut apprendre c'est court pour
éviter une interdiction définitive de
passer son bac